Dinosaurier, Dinosaurier, Dinosaurier, Dinosaurier. Einen wunderschönen guten Abend, hallo und herzlich willkommen zu dieser neuen Ausgabe von Das Podcast UFO. Schön, dass ihr wieder mit dabei seid, natürlich auch hier gerade reingestreunert, Stefan T. Und gegenüber sie von mir sitzt, gut gelaunt, frisch geduscht, flucht in Wille. Dankeschön, man muss ja wirklich sagen, dass sich der Aufnahmezeitpunkt unseres Podcasts mit der Zeit immer weiter nach vorne verschoben hat. Mittlerweile sind wir bei 6.30 Uhr angekommen, der erste Bus ist noch nicht gefahren, ich musste hierher laufen zu unserem neuen Büro. Ich habe mittlerweile einfach einen sechs Uhr dreissig Bürojob. Ich bin ausgezogen, um Podcaster zu werden, um weg von diesen kapitalistischen Fesseln zu kommen, die anderen Leuten die die Hufe abschnüren, wenn sie jeden Tag zur Arbeit traben müssen, um die Mühle zu ziehen. Und jetzt plötzlich bin ich wieder angekommen. Nee, ich mache es ja nur wegen meiner Stimme, weil dann hat man morgens noch diese Radiostimme.
Ja, da bin ich aufgestanden.
In diesem Sinne, hallo und herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen Ausgabe des Das-Podcast-Ufo-Podcast-Projektes mit mir, Stefan Thietze und dir, Florentin Will und euch. Vielen Dank, Herr Therano, natürlich auch vielen, vielen Dank an Julia und Johannes für dieses tolle, tolle Intro, die uns wieder mal in prähistorische Zeiten versetzen. Vielen Dank dafür, aber hier sei nochmal angemerkt,, dass wir kein, ich wiederhole nicht, ausschließlich ein Dino-Podcast sind. Nein, wir haben auch andere Themen, wie zum Beispiel lustige Alltagsbeobachtungen oder Fluch der Karibik, das Piraten-Ufo. Also wir sind vielseitig. Die Piratos von Haribo, wir sind also entweder Piraten schon oder Dinosaurier, aber... Da kurz eine Schleife dran zu machen an diese Piratosnummer, weil du da ja nochmal extra nachgefragt hast. Ja. Ich habe ja Pirators eingeführt als das stärkste Lakritze der Welt, das so stark ist, dass auf der Packung kein kindlicher Lars Kritze drauf sein durfte, damit Kinder da nicht aus Versehen reinlangen und dann dieses ja quasi fast pure Asbestlakritz da in sich reinschaufeln und deswegen dieser männliche furchtentflössende Pirat da drauf sein muss. So habe ich das erklärt. Zwei Stunden später schickt mir jemand ein Bild. Ah, guck mal, hier ist ja Lars Kritzer als Pirat verkleidet auf Pirathaus. Also, es gibt kein System, es gibt keine Regeln in Bonn. Ich weiß nicht, was da los ist in Bonn, warum die Behörden schlafen, warum dann nicht immer jemand ein Auge drauf hat, es gibt keine Regeln, es gibt kein System, wir sind einfach auf Freifahrt. Hassenregeln Bonn. Ja. Das ist nicht Hans-Riegel-Bonn, Hassenregeln-Riegeln-Bonn. Naja, ich verstehe es auch nicht so ganz. Ist aber auch, also ich verstehe auch nicht, warum manche, und das habe ich erfahren, was denn Lakritz? Ich meine, Lakritz ist manchmal verboten.
Gewisse oder nicht? Hast du davon auch schon mal gehört? Ich weiß, dass
Lakritze tödlich sein kann.
Und ich glaube, du musst, wir haben das mal ausgerechnet, glaube ich,
40 Packungen Lakritzschnecken
essen, dann kommst du in eine tödliche
Dosis Richtung. Also du musst
wirklich richtig viel Lakritz essen.
Was aber nicht so viel ist, wie man jetzt denkt.
Ich glaube schon. Also ich glaube, du tust dir schon schwer.
40 Packungen. Nach vier Packungen wirst du...
Aber meinst du diese großen Dosen?
Diese... Das kann auch sein.
Ja, ja, ja. Wenn du davon 40 isst.
Es kann schon sein. Also du musst wirklich
den ganzen Tag nichts anderes essen und glaube ich
auch durchgehen, weil irgendwann sagt dein Körper auch,
jetzt ist genug Lakritz. Und bei sowas ist es ja auch nicht so,
dass wenn du dann die 40. Box isst,
dass es dir dann erst schlecht geht. Das verstehen ja auch viele nicht. Dir geht es schon ab Box drei so dermaßen daneben. Ich bin natürlich da sofort im Kurzgeschichtenmodus und dachte mir, okay, das ist der perfekte Mord. So kennt man dich, du bist immer dann recht schnell im Kurzgeschichtenmodus. Absolut, klar, eine Novelle ist auch mal schnell geschrieben. Merfe ich mich, die auch Weihnachten zu feiern. Du bist ganz schnell im Kurzgeschichtenmodus. Absolut. Und da ist natürlich auch die Frage, kann man dann Mord? Also ich denke jetzt an Agatha Christie, die das natürlich gießen würden in einen perfiden Mordplan, wo man sagt, kann man dem Opfer in irgendeiner Weise 40 Packungen Lakritzschnecken unbemerkt unterjubeln. Also ich dachte mir, dadurch, dass sie ja diese Schnurform haben, ist es ja vielleicht möglich, dass man, also zum Beispiel einen Teller Spaghetti, da kann man ja leicht mal so zwei, drei reintun und sagt, ja, das ist irgendwie Oktopusblut oder Oktopustinte, das hat ein bisschen herben Geschmack. Der Nachteil ist halt so, dass sie einfach schwarz sind, dass es die unnatürlichste Farbe ist, die im Essen vorgibt. Aber es gibt ja schwarze Spaghetti, diese Oktopustintenfisch-Spagattardien. Da kennst du dich aus in dieser Old Cuisine. Ich meine, haben Oktopus nicht auch acht Spaghetti um sich herum? Genau. Kann man nicht einfach da sagen? Da wurde mir übrigens korrigiert, nicht alle Arne einer Krake sind Tentakel. Nur zwei, right? Genau. Sehr gut. Ich habe dich korrigiert. Du warst es. Du schreibst diese Mails immer so.
Wenn ich im Podcast nicht zu Wort komme oder es mir nicht einfällt, schreibe ich das danach, einfach als saure Hörermail getarnt.
Aber apropos Beschwerdemails, ich habe diese Woche auch überlegt, eine Beschwerdemail zu schreiben.
Und zwar, es ist kein Geheimnis, ich bin Freund der Fruchtwaffe.
Einer der wenigen Menschen.
Okay, ich war bei Fruchtwaffe, ich war bei Banane. Ich war bei der Fruchtwaffe. Einer der wenigen Menschen. Okay, ich war bei Fruchtwaffe, ich war bei Banane. Ich war bei der Fruchtwaffe. Die Fruchtwaffe, ja. Die eigentliche Vitaminbombe, die eigentliche Fruchtwaffe ist eine Banane, es stimmt schon. Oder die Granatapfel, eins, also vorbei. Du bist eigentlich komplett ausgestattet, kannst eigentlich direkt in den Krieg ziehen. Sorry, ich habe mich falsch verstanden, du meinst die Fruchtwaffe. Ich meine Fruchtwaffel. Es gibt ja immer so Produkte, wo man sich fragt, wer zur Hölle ist das? Und die Antwort ist, ich. Wenn ihr euch fragt, diese Jahrmarktwaffeln, dieser Schaumwaffel-Eimer, wer kauft denn sowas? Ich, ich bin's. Und du musst natürlich auch immer, sagen wir mal, supralokal denken, weil du in deinem eigenen Supermarkt einmal im Jahr vielleicht diesen Eimer hast, das heißt, du musst auch in andere Bundesländer gucken, hier und da Eimer abgreifen, das heißt, der gesamte deutsche Bundesmarkt ist eigentlich in meiner Hand und jetzt kommt natürlich wahrscheinlich den meisten Leuten ein bestimmter Name in den Kopf, die fünf Fruchtigen. Die fünf fruchtigen ist ein Standard-Repertoire in der Fruchtwaffel-Business und es sind diese langen Fruchtwaffeln sehr dünn. Es gibt zwei verschiedene Arten von diesen Fruchtwaffeln. Es gibt einmal die mit Schokolade vorne und hinten, die aber wie so ein Big Mac drei Schichten haben. Und dann gibt es die fünf fruchtigen, die nur so eine Schicht haben, weiß und rot. Google gerne mal, weil da ganz interessant, dass diese Packung, diese ganz billig produzierte, eigentlich nur aus Zucker, vermischt mit Zucker und rotem Farbstoff hergestellten Waffel. Ich war kurz bei Macarons. Ne, ne, die hat mit Macarons gar nichts zu tun. Ich war kurz bei Luxemburger League, das eins zu eins aussieht wie Macarons. Dann war ich bei Emmanuel Macron. Aber jetzt bist du ganz woanders. Jetzt bist du in Geschichte von Frankreich.
Die meinst du, jetzt verstehe ich alles.
Die fünf Fruchtigen.
Die meinst du.
Genau, die fünf Fruchtigen.
Und die sind recht dünn.
Männerartigen, neapolitanischen Waffeln.
Ja, so ein bisschen an einer Schicht Fruchtschaum.
Und da gibt es, und das ist ganz toll, weil eigentlich ist es so, es gibt ja so diese Produkte, die so unglaublich billig sind.
Für die wird keine Werbung gemacht.
Die gibt es immer so, die werden so von den Wägen geworfen bei Karneval. Das sind diese merkwürdigen Arten von Produkten, die haben keine Marketingfirma-Abteilung, die haben einfach nur … Die haben auch keinen Hersteller. Oben steht nichts drauf. Die sind einfach gemacht. Die entstehen einfach. Ich glaube, auch wenn du einen Supermarkt eröffnest, liegen die schon in den Regalen. Das ist Geschenk zum Supermarkt. Die sind einfach schon da. Und jetzt habe ich aber festgestellt, dass tatsächlich diese Packung mit den fünf Waffeln heißt, hat einen Namen, die fünf Fruchtigen. Und es sind Cowboys. Es sind fünf, du kannst ja gerne mal googeln, die fünf Fruchtigen, es sind sind fünf Cowboys und irgendjemand da draußen, und ich spreche dich jetzt direkt an, hat die Lore, die Hintergrundgeschichte dieser fünf Schaumwaffel Cowboys, wo die irgendwann die Entscheidung gefallen ist, das sind Cowboys. Nichts erinnert an Cowboys, es sind einfach Fruchtwaffel. Wenn man es googelt, merkt man schon, also selbst bei der Google-Bildersuche merkt man schon, das ist was, das wird nicht häufig gegogelt. Wir sind an einem Punkt angekommen im Internet, da waren noch nicht viele vorher. Absolut. Man hat so einen Entdeckercharakter, so einen Pionierinstinkt, bewegt das ein. Die fünf Fruchtigen, um kurz alle reinzuholen, sind einfach Waffeln mit Stiefeln, eine Frau ist dabei, zwei Frauen sind dabei. Alle haben unterschiedlich farbene Hüte auf. Wir haben den hellblauen, den schwarzen, den dunkelblauen, dann haben wir blonde Haare und einen roten Hut. Genau. So, der schwarze ist der Sheriff, verschränkt die Arme, der andere hat ein Lasso, die anderen, alle sind ausschließlich mit cowboyartigen Gegenständen. Ja, einer scheint der Sheriff zu sein, mit einem schwarzen Hut vorne. Und erst mal, also da muss, erst mal, mich ärgert einfach, dass es heißt, die fünf Fruchtigen, obwohl es nur zwei verschiedene Sorten sind. In meinen Augen gibt das keinen Sinn. Ich verstehe, dass fünf in der Packung sind, aber du kannst nicht sagen, die fünf Fruchtigen, wenn es zwei verschiedene Sorten sind. Ein Gegenbeispiel.
Wäre nicht auch besser, so auf the good, the bad and the ugly zu gehen dann, wenn man schon kauft, die saure, die fruchtige und die süße? Genau, sowas in der Richtung. Oder so bei den M&Ms, wo du die verschiedenen Arten hast, die dann so dastehen. Und das ergibt für mich einfach keinen Sinn. Nimm zum Beispiel Nimm zwei. Dieses Produkt heisst Nimm zwei, nichtimm sechzig, weil in der Packung sechzig Bongons drin sind. Nimm zwei, weil zwei Arten. Warum heißen die die fünf Fruchtigen? Nein, nein, nein, ich dachte, das wäre meine Verzehranleitung, dachte ich. Immer. Nimm zwei. Nein, weil es ist Orange und Zitrone. Es sind zwei Sorten. Ich habe so wie Peter Lustig, jetzt machen wir das Fernseher aus, mässig verstanden,
ne, nehm zwei. Und das hat bei dir gereicht,
dass einfach auf der Packung steht, iss mich
und du sagst, iss mich, ach so.
Ne, ne, eher so, ne, eher dosier dich,
nehm zwei. Ach, nehm nur zwei?
Nehm nur zwei, habe ich es gelegen. Bis zu zwei.
Nimm zwei. Drei brauchst du nicht.
Kannst drei nehmen,
ich rate, nehm zwei. Nimm zwei
reicht. Du siehst das als Obergrenze, ich sehe es eher als Untergrenze.
Ich sehe es als Verzehr-Empfehlung. Zwei. Ach so, ich dachte immer, wenn du schon dich reinschnabulierst, mindestens zwei, weil es sind zwei Sorten, sonst würdest du ja das gar nicht verstehen, dass es zwei Sorten sind. Clever. So, und deswegen heisst es, nimm zwei, zwei Sorten. Die frünfruchtigen hingegen, und jetzt hast du schon ganz angemerkt, in der Packung sind drei Weisse und zwei Rote. Und auf der Packung sind zwei Frauen und drei Männer. Ist das Absicht, ist das gewollt, dass die Pinken weiblich sind und die Weissen männlich? Ja, ich glaube, das ist die Idee, ne?
Ist das die Idee dahinter? Aber auch die Hutfarbe müsste ja dann eigentlich passen zur Schaum, Zuckerschaumfarbe, passt ja auch nicht zusammen. Weil die Illustration ist recht clever, du siehst die Waffel nämlich von vorne, so dass du nicht siehst, welche Füllung welche Figur hat. Die sehen für mich ungefüllt aus, da bin ich ganz ehrlich. Die sehen für mich wie die Waffel zwischen dem Schaum aus. Ja, aber das kann natürlich auch sein, dass es eigentlich, du hast eigentlich zehn Fruchtige in der Packung, weil du hast zehn Waffeln und die Füllung, und deswegen, ich kenne ja die Lore nicht, ich kenne ja die Geschichte nicht, ich weiß nicht, warum sind das Cowboys, was machen die den ganzen Tag, sind alle Figuren in dieser Welt Waffeln oder gibt es dann auch andere Arten von Süßigkeiten in dieser Welt, was machen die, was haben die für Aufgaben, diese fünf fruchtigen? Ist es eine Familie, ist es so eine Art Renegade-Crew? Warum ist der eine Sheriff geworden? Ich habe einfach viele Fragen, weil irgendjemand hat sich das ja ausgedacht und hat gesagt, was könnten denn Schaumwaffeln sein? Ritter, Freischerler, Landsknechte, Zyklopen vielleicht? Können wir ein bisschen mehr in so eine popkulturelle Richtung denken, vielleicht irgendwie Cowboys, Ninjas. Ja, vielleicht so ein Junker oder so, fünf Junker vielleicht in der Richtung. Nee, ich dachte eher noch popkultureller. Oder vielleicht so Dryaden. Okay, du bist raus, du bist raus. Cowboys, wir machen Cowboys. Dann nehme ich meinen Hut und gehe. Kling, kling, kling. Sporen haben die nicht, Sporen haben die nicht. Dauren haben die nicht. Na ja, haben die denn Pferde? Nein, auch nicht. Sind das einfach Waffeln, die auf Pferden reihen? Ich komme in einer Welt, wo Menschen Waffeln sind. Was sind dann Pferde? Und vor allem, was sind Waffeln? Was essen die dann? Sind das kleine schreiende Menschen? Und deswegen dachte ich, ich schreibe eine gepfefferte Mail. Oh mein Gott.
Was das denn soll?
Weil ich finde, die sollten sich erstmal umbenennen in die zwei Fruchtigen, fünf Stück. Weil was machen die denn, wenn die eines Tages sagen, wir machen eine Packung, wo zwanzig drin sind? Sind es dann die zwanzig Fruchtigen oder die fünf Fruchtigen mal vier? Offenbar haben die gar kein Problem mit einer Differenz und einer Diskrepanz zwischen Anzahl an Helden und Anzahl an Farben oder Geschmacksrichtungen. Dass du die jetzt da so runter drauf nageln willst. Oh, warte mal ganz kurz, ich sehe gerade hier eine Packung mit drei pinken und zwei weissen. Was natürlich die Cowboy, Cowgirl, ach die zuckerfreien! Ja. Es gibt die auch in Zuckerfrei. Vor allem, es gibt die aber auch als Packung komplett unbeschriftet. Also das ist wirklich diese Art von Produkt, die nichts hat. Und das finde ich so spannend, weil diese Produkte haben nichts, die haben keine Werbung, die haben kein Marketing, die haben nur dieses Cowboy-Element. Aber du drehst auch langsam gerade durch ein bisschen. Mich macht das wahnsinnig, weil du bist langsam, ich mache mir langsam ein bisschen Sorgen, dass du einfach in dem... Nein, ich finde, das ist einfach ein Fehler. Das ist einfach ein Fehler, weil du kannst doch keine Geschichte machen. Hast du geschlafen diese Nacht? Ich habe zu lang geschlafen. Ich habe mich seit unserer letzten Aufnahme hingelegt und habe durchgeschlafen bis heute Morgen. Aber du kannst doch keine Story erzählen mit die fünf Fruchtigen und das sind einfach nur zwei verschiedene. Weißt du, du hast die Power Ranger, da hat jeder eine andere Farbe und jeder einen anderen Charakter. Cool. Du hast Ducktales, da sind alles Enten. Okay, aber du hast unterschiedliche Figuren. Nehm ich. Suspension of disbelief. Ja, ja, ja, aber du kannst nicht sagen, die fünf Fruchtigen, wenn es zwei ist. Ich prangere das an und ich glaube, wer auch immer sich diese Cowboy-Idee ausgedacht hat, sitzt seitdem mit Angst im Büro und denkt sich, hoffentlich callt mich keiner auf meine dumme Hintergrundgeschichte, auf der anderen Seite, falls ihr noch Storys braucht, ich bin Kurzgeschichten-Fan, ich schreibe euch gerne, wie die fünf fruchtigen Cowboys geworden sind. Kannst du mir denn mal erzählen, was für eine gepfefferte, fiese Mail du geschrieben hast? Ich habe noch keine Mail geschrieben. Die ist noch imstande. Okay, wir schreiben. Es gibt in dieser Stadt nicht genug Platz für fünf. Lass mal eine Mail, wir öffnen mal eine Mail. Es ist mal wieder Zeit für unsere... Ich habe sieben Textdokumente offen. Willst du in letzte Folge oder willst du in Song? Was für einen Song schreibst du dir? Mach mal Command M. Ich schreib keinen Song, ich hab nur irgendwann mal, wir haben mal für die Neo-Magazin Anne-Will-Nummer. Seitdem ist der offen, der Tab. Genau, Neo-Magazin Anne-Will-Nummer, wo Anne-Will zu Gast war und dann ist dieses multidimensionale Jan fällt durch alle verschiedenen. Da mussten wir einen Song schreiben, weil Jan bei Markus Lanz saß, um seinen neuen Song vorzustellen. Weil das war diese, ich habe Polizei Zeit, wo jeder Song viral war und er sah jetzt seinen neuen Song. Da mussten wir einen Song schreiben, der auch Verstrickungen hatte, anderes Thema. Und um diesen Song zu schreiben, habe ich das Dokument geöffnet, Song, und seitdem ist das mein Go-To-Dokument. Das ist mittlerweile auch wirklich extrem lang, weil es ist halt so wie der laufende Notizblock. Aber dann Props an Apple, dass du inzwischen den dritten MacBook danach hast und immer noch dieses Dokument auf ist. Und das sind alle Aufzeichnungen, die ich mir immer gemacht habe. Hier zum Beispiel Reisevlog, Ende, Bali Bali Bali auflösen und dramaturgisch mehr gegen Ende. Übrigens, haben wir denn jemals gemacht diesen Reisevlog? Ja, mit Bali Bali Bali. Ah ja, ich erinnere mich. Oder hier, 100 Folgen das Podcast UFO, wie schaust du zurück, was sind deine Top 60 Folgen? Also einfach Notizen für irgendwas gemacht und es ist alles offen einfach. Okay, lass mal reinschreiben. Oh, da war auch noch dieser eine Talkshow-Sketch, den ich gerne gemacht hätte. Aber da können wir irgendwann mal in der großen, was wäre, wenn wir lustig gewesen wären Folge, können wir alles nochmal aufbauen. Wissen wir denn, wie die Hersteller heisst? Nee, ne ne, kriegt man auch nicht raus. Die fünf Fruchtigen. Ist es nicht so, dass ein Hersteller bei Google schreit, hier, ich, wir waren das. Okay, howdy. Howdy. In dieser Stadt ist nicht ... Oder vielleicht zu Händen Sheriff. Ja, oder hat er überhaupt Hände? Zu Händen, in Klammern, zu Waffelhänden, Sheriff, haben Hände, also ich sehe Hände. Sheriff, Howdy, Partner. Okay, erst zu Waffelhänden, Sheriff, Komma, Howdy, Komma, Partner, Ausrufezeichen. Wenn ihr nämlich eins gelernt habt von den Mails, die wir hier zusammenschreiben mit euch, das Podcast-Suche-Podcast-Projekt, dann immer mit einem unzugänglichen Gag einsteigen, den man als Lehrer noch nicht verstehen kann. Wo man merkt, die machen sich schon seit einer halben Stunde Gedanken und sind schon viermal abgebogen und du hast einfach keine Chance mehr. Brainstorming zu spät abgebrochen. Ja. Gut. Wir kamen nicht umher, festzustellen.
Umhin?
Wir kamen nicht umhin, dass etwas, dass Ärger in der Luft liegt.
Die Luft ist mit Frucht gewürzt.
Die Luft ist mit Waffe gewürzt.
Schaumgummi.
Das ist kein Schaumgummi, die Luft ist mit Schaum gewürzt. Okay, jetzt ist es langsam problematisch. Wir haben jetzt halt zweimal Luft, ne? Ja, das ist das Problem in dieser E-Mail. Okay, dann können wir es kürzen. Wir kamen nicht umhin festzustellen, dass die Luft mit Schaum gewürzt ist. Sei. Okay, jetzt. Im Prinzip wollen wir doch einfach nur wissen, warum fucking Cowboys, ne? Girls, cowgirls, cowpersons. Es geht, es geht, Komma, wie so oft, um die fünf Fruchtigen. Sie sind fruchtig, keine Frage. Aber fünf? Ich komme auf zwei. Aber fünf? Ich komme auf zwei. Weiss und pink. In Klammern Rot? Rot? Erdbeer? Wer sind die fünf fruchtigen? Gibt es mehr Geschmacksrichtungen oder stehen sie eher sinnbildlich als Maskottchen ihrer Marke? Und das finde ich ja gut, wenn wir wieder die Familie das unterschreiben lassen, damit es nicht, weil wenn die sich so zwei hochrote Augenpaare vorstellen, die sehr taglich geschlafen haben und diese Mail schicken, weil sie diese Antwort brauchen, glaube ich, kriegt man eher eine genervte slash irritierte Mail zurück. Deswegen würde ich hier schreiben, wir würden uns sehr über eine Antwort freuen, Familie Sühner.
Aber ich würde noch ganz kurz, und was ist Ihre Geschichte? Wie wurden Sie Cowboys slash Girls? Cowpersons. Cowpeople. Wie wurden sie Cowpeople?
Sind die Pinken weiblich oder ist das Zufall? Beste Grüße.
Gibt es Freundschaften, Feindschaften, Liebschaften?
Gibt es Schaften?
In Klammern Freund minus Feind minus Lieb minus Waffel.
Beste Grüße und jetzt die die Offenigas.
Hände von den Waffeln oder sowas, so ein Waffelgag, Waffel Waffengag.
Waffeln hoch?
Mhm.
Legen Sie die Waffel weg.
Legen Sie die Waffel weg. Legen Sie die Waffel weg.
Mit freundlichen Grüßen Familie Sünner aus Köln. Aus dem sonnigen Fönn, bin ich immer noch wichtig. Familie Sünner aus dem sonnigen Köln.
Man verzeiht nämlich solche Mails eher in der Familie, sag ich dir, dass sie nicht irgendwie, weißt du, dann hat doch ein Kind irgendwie eine Idee gehabt und so und der Vater konnte das nicht löschen. Warte mal, das ist Grabova. Grabova. Gründung 1835. Genau so sieht nämlich eure Verpackung noch aus. Das ist Wild Wild West, aber noch aus eigener Erfahrung. Ja. Früher, es waren Waffeln. Ich stelle euch Cowboys anders vor, es waren Waffeln. Grabova war Süsswaren. Aber jetzt haben wir mittlerweile, das ist schon die vierte, ne? Neben Hitchies, Haribo und Trolli haben wir jetzt schon in den letzten Folgen die vierte Firma gefunden. Geschichte, das Unternehmen wurde 18... jetzt kann ich meine Morgenstimme benutzen. Das Unternehmen Grabo war, wurde 1835 in Grabo durch Johann Bollhagen als Backstube gegründet, die Brezeln, Waffeln und Pfeffernüsse herstellten. Was sind Pfeffernüsse? 1902 übernahm es Gustav Ritter, der das Vertriebsgebiet ausdehnte und mit dem Export begann. 1951 wurde das Unternehmen in Volkseigentum überführt und firmierte als VEB Grabova Dauerbackwaren. Hergestellt wurden vor allem Schaumküsse und Gebäck. Gut, okay. Ich würde gerne bei Galileo diese Sachen auch einsprechen. Ich habe Betreff die zwei fruchtigen, um direkt mal reinzugehen.
Und ich hoffe, wir können es hören. Ich schicke das Ganze jetzt ab.
Wobei sie gehören... Achtung!
Kann nicht verbunden werden. Gut. Warte. Wow, das war ja fix. Für sieben Kilowater, da muss er ganz schön arbeiten. Da muss er jetzt dampfen. Okay, also Beef ist geschickt. Ich sag mal so, ab jetzt ist es außer unseren Händen. Es kann sein, dass wir gleich eine Staubwolke am Horizont sehen
und die fünf fruchtigen Persönlich sich auf den Weg machen zu uns.
Nächstes Intro ist dann, damit irgendwann unsere Intros gar nicht mehr verstanden werden können von Leuten, die dazukommen,
ist dann so eine Wir sind fruchtig, suchen schmackhaft alle Waffen. Wir sind fruchtig und herb zugleich. Wir sind die fünf fruchtigen. So was in der Art hätte ich gerne als Lied. Ich bin weiss, ich bin rot, ich bin auch weiss, ich bin pink,. Ich bin ein Girl. Ich bin auch weiß. Wir sind alle recht ähnlich. Stell dir mal vor, es hätte bei den Power Rangers zwei Blaue gegeben. Einfach sagst, wie du, hä, ich dachte, du machst Lila. Ich habe doch gestern in der Mail gesagt, ich bin blau. Ich habe gesagt blau. Ausserdem bin ich nicht blau, ich bin Cyan, okay? Ja, ich bin Ultramarin. Ja, aber wir sehen fast exakt ... Einer von uns muss sich umziehen. Guck mal, das ist ein anderes Shade of Blue. Es ist ein bisschen dunkelblauer. Das funktioniert so überhaupt nicht. Was ist dein Megasort hier? Oh nein, da hinten kommt Dave auch in Blau. Sag mal, das ist doch nicht dein Ernst! Nein! Wir haben gesagt Farbe. Nein, Melanie, auch blau. Leute, wir können uns so nicht zeigen, wir sind alle blau. Ich habe eine Idee, wir trommeln und verkaufen für sehr viel Geld Tickets, wir sind alle blau. Irgendwie, I think it makes sense, wenn wir jetzt anfangen zu trommeln. Aber meint mal, wir haben hier kein Geld mehr, uns trommeln zu leisten. Worauf sollen wir denn trommeln? Auf unseren Helmen trommeln wir jetzt. Ja, ich habe nur noch diesen alten Bambusstock und diesen Eimer. Super, genau das machen wir. Und wir sammeln Geld, um uns andere Kostüme zu kaufen? Nö. Weil wir müssen weiterhin die böse Prinzessin Gravotunia besiegen. Ja, aber es können ja Grau, Ocker, Kaki und Beige machen. Okay, dann geht ihr schon mal los. Einfach so diese Pastel-Power-Range. Das ist eine leichte Farbe. Ja, ist schwierig. Es ist nicht leicht, so eine Superheldengruppe zu machen. da gibt es immer Streit. Das finde ich immer einen guten Paradies-Sketch.
Parodie oder Paradies?
Parodie. Kaki, Ocker, Bisch und Moff machen gemeint, sind so eine B-Rangers, weil natürlich gab es am Anfang so Jackson-Farben mässig, verschiedene Pantone-Farben und wir haben halt die Klassiker wurden halt genommen für die Hauptstory. Aber dann gibt es bestimmt noch ein paar andere Farben, diese Zwischentöne. Ich finde es ja, das Interessante ist, bei so Superhelden-Sachen wie Batman, finde ich immer so die Imitatoren, dass du irgendwann normale Bürger hast, die sich auch so ein Superhelden-Kostüm bauen und die dann auch Batman sein wollen und imitieren. Und das kann es ja auch geben bei Power Rangers, die dann einfach Ocker, Ocker, Hellgrau und Halbtransparent sind dann unterwegs und versuchen auch, Doktor Ocker, der Bösewicht, der erste große Bösewicht, Doktor Ocker. Ja, finde ich gut. Ich finde eh, dass das Power Ranger Franchise so ein bisschen untergegangen ist irgendwie. Ich kann mich noch ganz gut erinnern, dass ich als Kind Riesen Power Rangers Fan war und ich immer diese Sticker gesucht habe, weil es gab so manche Franchise, die waren riesengroß, Pokémon Sticker, Fussballsticker und so, aber ich hatte dieses Sammelheft für Power Rangers Sticker und die gab es fast nirgendwo und natürlich sind diese Alben furchtbar, weil du so lange Sticker kaufen musst, bis du das Album voll hast und die habt ihr nirgendwo gefunden. Und mein Vater und ich haben uns am Wochenende immer auf die Suche gemacht und sind teilweise in München bis zum Flughafen gefahren, weil wir dachten, da gibt es mehr Sticker, weil da gibt es halt diese Läden, wo es weirde Produkte gibt. Und wir dachten, ja, das wird da vielleicht es geben. Es gibt entweder mehr Sticker oder gar keine Sticker. Ja, aber es gibt definitiv einen Unterschied zum normalen Sticker-Fundus der Alltagswelt. Alles ist anders. In Städten kannst du Mackenkissen nicht kaufen. Wohingegen du kannst Koffer kontraintuitiv an Flughäfen kaufen. Why? Wenn du mit deiner ganzen Kleidung im Arm da hinkommst, sagst, ach, ich dussel, wusste doch, da gibt es was, was man leichter nehmen kann. Das habe ich noch nie verstanden, Koffer. Ja, das ist merkwürdig. Aber kleiner Spoiler-Alarm, es gab auch am Flughafen keine Power Ranger Stickers. Mein Vater ist aber großer Computerfan und Programmierer und hatte relativ schnell mit dem Internet zu tun. Und dann hat er mir eines Tages gesagt, ja, Florentin, ich habe jetzt mal im Internet gesucht nach Power Ranger Stickern. Und ich erinnere mich so klar an diese Argumentation, er meinte, es ist aber sehr schwer, nach Power Rangers zu suchen, weil ich dann immer irgendwelche Farmer und Bauern in Amerika finde, so Ranger. Und ich dachte mir, sehr gute Ranger, die besten. Stark, Arranger. Und ich dachte mir schon damals, stimmt, es ist schwer im Internet nach Begriffen zu suchen, die auch eine andere Bedeutung haben.
Vater, ich akzeptiere das als Entschuldigung, dass du mir die Sticker verwehrst. Und ich kann mich noch so gut daran erinnern, dass er sagt, ich finde hier nur sexy Cowboys und ich finde nur sexy Leute in Naturschutzgebieten, aber leider nicht deine Power Ranger. Bis heute ist das Album nicht gefüllt. Und bis heute besteht das Problem, dass manche Dinge nicht googelbar sind, weil die zu allgemeingültig heißen. Ja, absolut. Deswegen, wenn ihr einen Film macht, nennt ihn nicht Kiss oder so. Nennt ihn lieber The Wisdom of Chaos oder so. Einfach einen längeren mit vielen Of The. Weil das ist nichts anderes. Da kannst du dann einfach wissen, wonach du suchst. The Batman. The Batman, the Batman. The Batman. The Batman. Ich dachte, wir kriegen so viele Nachrichten von Leuten, die sagen, ich habe den Wecker im Speicher, ich habe auch schon mal von dieser Geschichte mit dem Batman-Wecker gehört. Nichts. Full disclosure. Ja, nichts. Naja, pass auf, also um kurz alle mit ins Boot zu holen. Du hast es ja ausgedacht. Mit ganz offenen Karten zu spielen. Du hast gelogen. Nein, nicht dazu. Du hast es geträumt. Richtig. Ich, wir nehmen ja, streng genommen ist es der Aufnahmerhythmus nicht perfekt, um die Community einzubinden. Das willst du jetzt aber nicht leaken., das kannst du nicht liegen. Wir sind gerade Januar 2021. Nee, wir und das, ich möchte euch mit reinholen. Ich will euch rausdrücken. Ich will euch wieder rausdrücken. Ich will euch reindrücken. Holst du rein, dann drück ich sie wieder raus. Und deswegen haben wir uns für so ein Clubsystem entschieden. Wir lassen nur so viele Leute rein, wie rausgedrückt werden von Florentin. Ja, aktuell sind null drin. Von daher kannst du ein paar reinholen gerade. Okay, weil wir nehmen quasi montags auf oder dienstags. Oder mittwochs. Und samstags veröffentlichen wir. Heißt, wir kriegen nicht alles mit in der letzten Folge. Deswegen sind wir, und da müssen wir uns selber in die eigene Nase fassen, weil, gegenseitig, weil das ist vielleicht besser, wenn wir quasi von vor zwei Wochen die Community-Sachen reinbeziehen. Das müssen wir rotieren, ja, ja. Das heißt, zur Brezel-Story, wo ich schon sehr viel tolles Feedback gelesen habe. Können wir noch wenig sagen gerade. Und zum Batman können wir jetzt noch wenig sagen. Das stimmt. Da kommt erst noch viel rein. Die Folge hört ihr erst noch. Und falls ihr jetzt wirklich sagt, ich habe Bock nur auf Brezel und Batman, dann hört einfach immer die ungeraden Folgen. Genau. Weil das immer so die Folgen sind, wo Bezug genommen wird auf die jeweils zwei davor. Merken, Bezug nehmen nur auf eine gleiche Folge, gerade oder ungerade. Genau, völlig richtig. Wenn ihr ein Problem mit diesem Aufnahmerhythmus habt oder generell, dass wir euch nur alle zwei Folgen einbeziehen können, dann wendet euch doch bitte an zentrale-at-das-podcast-ufo.org. Oder, falls ihr nicht so lange auf die neue Folge warten wollt, dann kommt einfach in den UFO-Club auf patreon.com slash das Podcast UFO, dann kriegt ihr die neue Folge schon am Freitag. So, und dann haben wir noch eine ganz besondere Sache für euch, denn wir haben neuen Mörs. Na, endlich, endlich wieder diese coolen T-Shirts und Pullover, die Christoph Niemann designt hat? Nein, wir haben ein neues neu gemacht. Die sollen erst mal limitiert bleiben, vielleicht gibt es irgendwann noch mal eine Charge. Keine Ahnung, mal gucken, gerade stand er nicht. Wir haben aber zwei ständige Shirts, die wir in unseren Shop packen. Einmal in schwarz, einmal in weiß. Keine Angst, keine Panik, es ist kein Drop, es ist kein, es gibt nur x-so und so viele, es gibt nur bis zu dem Tag, sondern die T-Shirts, die jetzt im Shop sind, sind dauerhaft da, sind ein bisschen schlichter gehalten mit dem UFO-Logo, aber sie sind trotzdem sehr, sehr schick geworden, wir haben sehr, sehr unangenehme Fotos damit gemacht, wir sind kurz ins Model-Business eingetaucht, also schaut sie euch gerne an auf podcast-ufo.fail, da findet ihr unseren Shop und natürlich auch jeder Hinweis, falls ihr jetzt gross einkaufen wollt, UFO-Club-Mitglieder bekommen 10% Rabatt auf alle Merchprodukte. Also es lohnt sich vielleicht, da auch mal bei Patreon vorbeizuschauen. Ansonsten erst mal Ruhe. Entspannt euch. Es gab viel Trubel um den ersten Merch-Drop und ich kriege immer noch Nachrichten, wann der nächste kommt.
Jetzt habt ihr die Möglichkeit, euch zurückzulehnen und ihr wisst, das wird dauerhaft geben. Kann sein, dass die irgendwann ausverkauft sind, aber dann werden die auf jeden Fall wieder nachgefrischt, so wie es auf jeden Fall ist. Es ist keine Limitierung da. Aber vielleicht kommt irgendwann wieder limitierte Sachen. Wissen wir nicht, wir haben auf jeden Fall tolle Ideen für Anzüge, Hüte, Ohrenwärme. Anzüge finde ich gut, drei Teile. Richtig schöne Anzüge, Westen. Und könnt ihr auch nochmal schauen, vielleicht könnt ihr noch ein Ticket für die Tour ergattern, die jetzt, toi toi toi, bald, zwei, drei Wochen. Ab dem fünften, vierten starten wird, aber da müsst ihr euch wieder ein bisschen beeilen. Es ist immer ein bisschen Internet, es ist ein bisschen, man muss auch fix sein. Also ich finde es gut, dass du jetzt gerade so eine neue Philosophie anstattbringst. Entspannt euch mal. Aber das Internet ist halt oft nicht so entspannt. Es ist blitzschnell. Das Internet ist blitzschnell. Es ist nicht wie eine Flaschenpost damals, wo man in einem Jahr irgendwo ankommen ist. Nein, es ist blitzschnell. Bei dir gerade die Mail hat schon sehr lange gebraucht. Das hat wirklich, vor allem da stand 0,1 von 7 Kilobyte. Da hast du jetzt richtig in den Zeug geengängt, mein Freund. Da hast du jetzt mal richtig Gas gegeben. Das war schon, also so eine Brieftaube war eher gestartet zumindest. Die wäre jetzt noch nicht da, aber sie wäre eher gestartet. Ich bin gespannt, ob wir eine Antwort kriegen. Das können wir dann in vier Wochen auch dann wieder besprechen. Das ist dann alles klar. Aber Beschwerden müssen sein, denn Beschwerden machen die Welt besser. Hast du dich schon mal richtig saftig beschwertet? Du bist eher ein Beschwerer, ne? Du bist auch der, der
im Restaurant Sachen zurückgehen lässt.
Nein, das kann ich nicht.
Also ja, ich beschwere mich schon,
aber nicht
face to face. Also im Restaurant
habe ich generell immer die grösste Abneigung
davon, irgendwas dem Servicepersonal
gegenüber negativ zu
betiteln, weil das ist immer, die
haben einfach die Machtposition, weil sie literally
Teller mit Essen zu dir
tragen. Recht nah an ihren Körperöffnungen
und damit ist einfach die
Machtsituation klar. Ne, ich krieg
eher, ich hab neulich, da war ich sehr stolz drauf,
weil ich will ja geliebt werden von allen immer.
Und deswegen bin ich, tendenziell
kippt das eher ins Unangenehme.
Aber ich will so geliebt werden und neulich
habe ich, ich meine Begleitung haben im Restaurant gehört bekommen, also am Ende kam die Kellnerin zu uns und hat gesagt, ihr wart wirklich so tolle Gäste. Weil das Essen hat ein bisschen länger gebraucht, wir haben viel gelacht, trotzdem haben immer gesagt, alles gut, gar kein Problem, easy, haben Zeit und so. Und das war das beste Kompliment, was ich mir jetzt bekommen konnte. Das finde ich aber auch toll, dass Sie das sagen. Ja, habe ich auch gedacht. Von daher, also so, das bin ich im Restaurant. Okay. Aber danach, da kann es schon mal eine Mail geben. Ich habe einmal in einem Hotel geschlafen und danach, das war auch so ein bisschen teurer, und dann habe ich danach gedacht, das geht ja alles nicht. Weil ich bin dann auch, habe ich auch schon mal, glaube ich, hier erzählt, wenn es dann, ich will dann auch alles ausnutzen für den Preis. Also wenn ich das Gefühl habe, das ist gerade ein teures Hotel, dann will ich da auch alles machen, was es rechtfertigt. Ich will alle Vorteile ausnutzen, die ich bezahlt habe. Du willst beide Flaschen Mineralwasser trinken. Habe ich schon alles ausgetrunken und gegessen, was ich bezahlt habe? Das ist dann meine Frage in diesem Hotel. Du benutzt alle Gläser, die da stehen, einfach damit du alles benutztest. Habe ich so viel Frühstück gegessen, dass es den Aufpreis des Frühstücks rechtfertigt.
Bin ich so oft in den Pool gegangen, in diesem Dreckshotel, dass es das lohnt, diesen Aufpreis für jeden Bereich.
Ja, finde ich gut.
So, und da standen da Bierflaschen rum neben dem Pool und so, mein Wasser wurde nicht aufgefüllt, ist gar kein Klopapier mehr.
Also teilweise auch Essentials einfach.
Und dann habe ich danach einfach, und das dachte ich mir, wie schreibe ich jetzt eine Mail, dass die am meisten Impact hat? Und dann habe ich die unglaublich höflich geschrieben. Ich habe so höflich diese Punkte aufgezählt, super sachlich, richtige Rechtschreibung, weil ich immer denke, was nervt mich am meisten, wenn ich irgendwo einen negativen Kommentar bei mich lese, ist es doch das Schlimmste, wenn der in einer guten Rechtschreibung sachlich formuliert, in mehreren Absätzen nachvollziehbare Argumentation, da weil Begründungen, Erwartungshaltung, ich weiß, Ihre Arbeit ist schwer und Sie haben viele Zimmer, aber das trifft einer meisten. Deswegen habe ich dann so eine richtig nette Mail geschrieben. Aber es gab kein Wasser im Pool? Oder es war mit, was war das? Nee, sorry, es gab kein Wasser in meinem Zimmer und sehr viel im Pool. Aber Bierflaschen... Vielleicht bist du es vielleicht aus deinem Zimmer in den Pool gegangen. Wir haben gesagt, fuck, wir haben nicht genug Wasser für den Pool. Lass uns, okay, wir müssen jetzt handeln, wir müssen jetzt schnell denken. Rennt mal bitte in alle Zimmer und holt alles Wasser raus und stüttet es in den Pool. Ja, Kohlensäure, ob Kohlensäure oder nicht, ist erstmal scheißegal. Ist vielleicht sogar gar nicht so schlecht, in Kohlensäure zu baden, das ist vielleicht ganz gut. Ich bin ja, ich mache jetzt immer, ich bin ja ein Ritualmensch und man muss auch neue Rituale erfinden. Und jetzt haben wir diese tolle Situation, dass wir hier immer so wahnsinnig früh aufnehmen. Und deswegen laufe ich jetzt hier mein Herz auf unsere Brücke und unser tolles Büro! Die Kommandobrücke. Die Kommandobrücke. Und da komme ich immer vorbei an einem sehr tristen, deprimierenden Anblick, nämlich einem leeren See. Es ist ein See, der ist leer. Was in Köln schon mal besser ist als jetzt der Rest der Stadt. Ja. Weil zumindest gibt es da das Potenzial eines schnell zu einem Loch, wenn halt kein Wasser drin ist. Es ist halt einfach ein Erdloch und man denkt sich, wie arm sind wir dran, dass wir nicht diesen See mit Wasser füllen können? Wo ist das Wasser? Wer braucht das so dringend, dass die Stadt Köln gesagt hat, weg mit dem Wasser aus dem See, das wird ganz dringend woanders gebraucht. Nirgendwo ist ja, nirgendwo ist Dystopie und Utopie so nah beieinander. Ja. Ich meine, wenn da irgendwie dieses auch schon sehr schön gemachten so ein Park eingefasst, der ist ja auch so weiss. Und wenn da Wasser drin ist, ist es einfach wie Vegas von Bellagio. Wenn es aber leer ist, ist es veralgt, dann hilft das Weiss auch nicht mehr, ehrlich gesagt.
Es ist so, von allen Elementen, die in dieses Bauwerk fließen, Beton, Brunnen, Figur, denke ich mir, das Wasser ist doch das mitabschiedlich billigste.
The most essential.
Also das darf doch nicht fehlen, wenn alles da ist und das Wasser, ich meine, man könnte sagen, es regnet umsonst, kleiner Hint an die Kölner Stadt, aber trotzdem ist diese See einfach leer.
Und man kann auch noch ein bisschen mehr, Und das Wasser, ich meine, man könnte sagen, es regnet umsonst, kleiner Hint an die Kölner Stadt, aber trotzdem ist dieser See einfach leer und man sitzt da, will sich eigentlich entspannen, hat aber dieses weird deprimierende Bild dieses leeren Sees, das ist so wie ein Springbrunnen, der leer ist oder nicht läuft oder nicht springt, das ist einfach so, so nur dieses Skelett, so du weisst, es könnte richtig toll sein, ist es aber gerade nicht. Ich glaube, das Einzige, was gefehlt hat, ist, dass man unten diesen Ablauf reindrückt einmal. Das kann gut sein. Vielleicht müsste ich den selber reindrücken. Drück den mal rein. Den Ablauf. Weil es hat ja jetzt auch viel geregnet in den letzten Wochen, dass man, wenn man diesen Ablauf reingedrückt hätte richtig, wäre es vielleicht einfach schon mal so ein bisschen Wasser drin gewesen. Vielleicht hat es auch nur so viel geregnet, weil das Wasser aus dem See verdunstet ist. Ah ja. Und deswegen musste das
überall hin oder so. Ich stelle mir mal vor,
dass einfach da so ein großes Flugzeug gekommen ist
bei einem Waldbrand und hat einfach das
Wasser aus diesem See einfach leer geschlürft.
Da fragt ja auch, also ich stelle mir
dann vor, nach dem Waldbrand alles ist gelöscht,
man liegt sich in den Arm, man sagt, gut
gemacht, sagt irgendjemand, oh,
jetzt müssen wir das Wasser noch erneuern, das wir übergeholt haben mit unseren Flugzeugen. Das sagt doch kein Mensch. Die Leute, der Abspann Das ist ein sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, gut gemacht, sagt irgendjemand, oh, jetzt müssen wir das Wasser noch erneuern, das wir übergeholt haben mit unseren Flugzeugen. Sagt doch kein Mensch. Der Abspann läuft schon. Die Leute, der Abspann läuft, die gehen nach Hause, wir sind schon beim Best Boy und Grip. Also niemand kümmert sich mehr darum, so der Pool von dem Typen, wo wir das Wasser geholt haben, kümmert sich kein Mensch drum. Und es kann ja auch passiert sein, dass das einfach geholt wurde. Best Boy, Flontenville, Good Boy, Boy, Stefan T. Das fände ich nicht so schlecht, wenn es im Abspann auch noch Best Boy und Good Boy, Okay Boy, Average, Mediocre Boy und Bad Boy. Und dann aber wieder Bad Boy ist aber auch wieder cool. Bad Boy ist wieder Florentin. Und Worst Boy will es aber auch nicht sein. Das stimmt schon. Aber. Aber ich habe nur mal so ein Video gesehen, wo so ein Helikopter mit so einer großen Kanne, mit so einer großen Tonne aus einem privaten Pool Wasser abgeschöpft hat. Die haben wahrscheinlich auch nicht gefragt oder so und einfach so, oh da ist ein Pool, lass uns da Wasser holen, vor Waldbrand. Und da war Papa drin, da war so eine Schwimmnudel drin, die dann irgendwo im Baum verschwort. Papa auf seinem Einhorn. Papa ist besoffen auf seinem Einhorn, nämlich eingepennt und ist damit dem Buch irgendwie im Namen der Rose. Ja, Papa schnorchelt gerade unter Wasser, wurde nicht gesehen vom Piloten und hängt jetzt im Baum drin. Und da denke ich mir auch so, bringen die das Wasser danach wieder zurück, dass sie dann sagen, hier ist euer Wasser? Nein, da muss man sich wahrscheinlich selber drum kümmern. Machen die das wirklich, die klauen Wasser aus Pools? Ich nehme an, dass die Wasser holen, was in der Nähe ist gerade. Das heißt, wenn du einen Pool in der Nähe von einem Wald hast, musst du damit rechnen, dass das abgeschöpft wird. Für einen guten Zweck. Ja, absolut. Ich würde mich freuen, ich würde sagen, geil. Wobei ich habe das Gefühl, dass so L.A., Hollywood Hills Pools, da ist so oft mal ein Drink reingefallen oder so, dass es eher brandbeschleunigend wirkt.
Aber das klingt für mich auch wieder so ein bisschen wie damals, als man seinen Eltern erklärt hat, man braucht jetzt eine Playstation, um darauf die Hausaufgaben zu machen.
Ich glaube, so ist es mit dem Pool auch.
Ich weiß, Schatz, Pool ist teuer, aber schau mal, wir sind direkt neben dem Wald und wenn der jetzt anfängt zu brennen, dann können wir mit unserem Pool helfen. Also da kannst du gut Argumente finden und sagen, ja, vielleicht brauchen wir den gar nicht, das ist einfach unser Beitrag zum Allgemeinwohl, dass der Waldbrand gelöscht werden kann, falls den unser dummer Sohn anentfacht oder so. Dann können wir mit dem Pool löschen helfen. Ja, ich weiß nicht. Okay. Denk doch bitte an den Wald, Schatz. Okay, warum haben wir noch mal so einen riesigen SUV in der Einfall stehen? Erklär mir das nochmal. Wenn du es mir erklärst, verstehe ich es, aber dann erkläre ich es meinen Freunden und die sagen dann, dein Mann verarscht. Nein, das Auto muss möglichst schwer sein, damit wir in der Wald brennt, wir durch eine Pfütze fahren können und das Wasser in den brennenden Wald spritzen können. Habe ich dir doch erklärt, Schatz. Ja, wenn du mir erklären, macht es Sinn. Okay, erklären wir nochmal, warum wir diesen riesigen Fernseher im Wohnzimmer stehen haben. Damit wir sehen, wenn der Wald brennt im Fernsehen. Und dann haben wir diese riesigen Weinfässer, die wir zur Not auch in den Wald werfen können. Ja genau, da wollte ich auch nochmal fragen, die Weinfässer. Damit können wir auch den Waldbrand löschen. Ja gut, aber die grossen Rumfässer, die sorgen jetzt nicht dafür, dass der Brand gelöscht wird. Damit können wir den Wald, den Brand auf eine falsche Fährte locken, weg von unserem Haus. Stimmt, weil es kann, stimmt, weil Flammen bleiben immer eine Anzahl. Ja genau, die werden weggeleitet. Die werden dann weggeleitet. Das habe ich dir doch alles erklärt. Ja, ich weiß, ich weiß, sorry. Also Pool, okay, ja. Guck mal, wir sind ein gutes Team. Wir sind ein gutes Team. High five. Und dann sind schön Pool. Ach, wäre auch nett, oder? Naja, es wird immer wärmer. Es wird immer wärmer, aber Wasser wird immer weniger. Mein Traum ist ja in der Rente, ich habe letztes Mal über Rente nachgedacht, weil ich glaube, Rente für unsere Generation ist ganz cool. Also nicht finanziell oder so Katastrophe, aber so von der Beschäftigung, weil wir sind alle mit Videospielen aufgewachsen, wir sind alle mit Serien, mit Streaming, mit Franchises aufgewachsen, ja, wir schauen dir immer noch Batman-Filme an, wenn wir 70 sind, weil wir sind damit aufgewachsen, so, wohingegen, wenn du Columbo-Fan bist, heutiger Rentner, das wird nicht mehr produziert, das wird wahrscheinlich als Hollywood-Franchise nicht mehr aufgewachsen. Kannst du dich gleich umbringen. Ja, kannst du dich direkt lassen. Als Columbo-Film kannst du dich direkt lassen. Ja, weil du schaust wahrscheinlich immer irgendwie Kino Plus oder andere Serien und denkst dir, wann kommt der neue Columbo-Film, wann geht die Serie weiter, wann kommt das Remake. Wird nicht passieren, Rainer, wird nicht passieren. Rainer, tschaui. Wohingegen, wenn du Fan von den Avengers bist, da wird es wahrscheinlich in 100 Jahren werden noch neue Filme gemacht. Du kannst Videospiele spielen und als Rentner würde ich gerne einen See graben. Ohne Wasser? Mit Wasser? Mit Wasser, wenn es geht. Aber erst mal bei Phase 1 stört ja das Wasser erst, weil du musst ja erst mal ein riesiges Loch graben. Ich verstehe nicht, das verstehe ich nicht. Warum willst du denn selber, also ist es dein Ziel? Das ist mein Ziel. Du willst selber einen See erstellen? Ja. Aber du gibst dich nicht zufrieden mit einem schönen Haus an einem bereits existierenden See. Nein, nein, nein, es ist doch viel leichter, ein schönes Haus zu finden und den See daneben zu graben, als ein Haus zu finden, das schon am See steht. Ich weiß nicht, wenn du da offen bist für den Standort, dann glaube ich, findest du leichter einen See als einen See zu erstellen. Selbst wenn ich neben dem See wohnen würde, ich würde ihn noch größer baggern, glaube ich. Auch wenn ich nicht genau weiß, wie das geht, weil wenn der See ja schon mit Wasser gefüllt ist, kannst du ja nicht, also du kannst ja dann, du müsstest ja dann erstmal leer machen oder du, was ich mir überlegt habe, du hast da ein See voller Wasser und du gräbst daneben ein weiteres Loch ohne Wasser. Und irgendwann wird diese Grenze zwischen See und Loch immer dünner, bis irgendwann der Damm bricht und das Wasser reinfließt. Hoffentlich nicht, während du mit deinem Bagger im See stehst. Weil sonst brauchst du einen noch grösseren Bagger, um den kleinen Bagger rauszubaggern aus dem See. Und Papa mit der Trüppullnudel wieder rauszuholen, ja. Aber das ist so meine Idee für die Rente. Hast du schon einen Plan, was du machst?
Nee, auch See. Aber auch ein See? Ja, auch ein See. Ach, das ist ja ein Zufall. Aber ich hätte gern einen bereits existierenden See, damit ich mich länger daneben setzen kann. Weil das klingt ehrlich gesagt, als ob du eine ganze Rente damit verbringst, diesen See schön zu machen. Ja, aber das ist doch viel schöner, neben dem See zu sitzen, den du selber gegraben hast, wo du einfach weißt, okay, da ist Arbeit reingeflossen. Ich bin kein Fan von diesen nie endenden Projekten. Also ich kenne ein paar Rentner aus dem Familienkreis, die haben so sich dann gewünscht, mal einen Garten zu haben und so was und arbeiten dann jetzt in ihrer Rente an einem Garten. Und für mich ist das so abstoßend, an etwas die ganze Zeit arbeiten zu müssen, was ja nie fertig wird. Also dieser Weg ist das zielmäßige, das Prinzip, auch bei einem Garten. Ich finde es schon nett, ab und zu mal im Garten was zu machen, zu arbeiten oder sowas. Aber ich komme damit nicht zurecht, dass das kein endliches Ziel ist. Also du machst dann eher sowas wie eine Seifenkiste. Gebaut, gefahren, gewonnen, erledigt. Weggeschmissen. Weggeschmissen, verkauft, bei Ebay verkauft. Wo du ein ganz klares Ziel hast, da fährst du durch und dann war es das auch wieder. Klare Ziele, dann wird es entsorgt und dann findest du in meiner Wohnung davon nichts mehr, ausser vielleicht den Pokal des dritten Platzes. Vielleicht, aber wahrscheinlich findest du nichts mehr. Wo du die Achtjährigen von der Strecke gedrängt hast. Ja, ja, genau. Das ist nämlich so, man soll am Ende nichts mehr davon überhaben. Es sind einfach klar getrennte Projekte. So ein Haus am See finde ich ja fantastisch, das Coolste. Mit so einem kleinen Steg, mit einem kleinen Bötchen, einer Angel. Ja, bis die Blaualgen kommen und irgendwie die Raubfische und alles. Die Blaualgen, ne? Ja. Wovor hast du mehr Angst, vor Raubfischen oder vor Blaualgen? Also ich habe ja Erfahrung gemacht mit Blaualgen. In meiner Heimatstadt Ebersberg wurde ja über lange Jahre der Klostersee geschlossen, weil ein Badegast Blaualgen mit Ausschlag hatte.
Und dieser Badegast hatte blaue Flecken. Und das wäre weiter nicht schlimm gewesen, wenn nicht die Mutter dieses Badegastes im Stadtrat gesessen hätte und dafür gesorgt hätte, dass aufgrund dieser Blaualgen dieser sehr, sehr beliebte Badesee, auch bei den Freunden dieses Badegastes, sehr beliebte Badesee, über Jahre, man könnte sagen, für den Rest der Kindheit, geschlossen wird. Ja, richtig, vielleicht hast du es erraten, dieser kleine junge Badegast, das war ich. Und ich war dafür verantwortlich, dass dieser sehr beliebte Badesee, Zentrum der Sommerfreude, über Jahre hinweg geschlossen wurde. Und dann kann man sich vorstellen, du hast nicht den besten Stand in deinem Freundeskreis. Korrekt, weil alle jetzt viel Zeit hatten im Sommer und eigentlich diese Zeit viele Plakate gemacht und gesagt haben, was machen wir, wollen wir nochmal den Typen mobben, der dafür verantwortlich ist, dass wir gerade nicht baden können? Ja, machen wir das doch. Und der See musste auch komplett ausgebaggert werden, weil die Algen ja irgendwie am Boden sind. Und der musste komplett ausgebaggert werden. Und jetzt hat der, das ist ganz cool, so einen Nebenbereich, so einen zweiten See, wo ganz viele Pflanzen sind, die das Wasser reinigen. Der hat so einen eigenen Reinigungskreislauf-Ding gedönst, wo halt die Roteigen drin sind, die alle Blaualgen zerstören. Aber du bist sofort zersetzt, wenn du in diesen anderen See gehst. Das auf gar keinen Fall. Wenn du da einen Fuß reinsetzt, da entstehen noch ganz merkwürdige Fische und sowas, so Pokémon-artige. Aber gut, aber der See ist jetzt wieder voll. Der See ist wieder voll, jetzt wou-Algenfrei? Jetzt, wo alle meine Freunde fürs Studium weggezogen sind, jetzt kann man da wieder baden. Was ist das Gegenteil von blau auf der Farbskala? Rot. So, dann würde ich doch einfach Rotalgen einsetzen und mal gucken, was passiert. Das ist ein gefährliches Spiel. Das ist ein gefährliches Spiel. Was ist, wenn die Rotalgen wieder überhand nehmen? Dann kommen entweder die Grünalgen. Oder was, wenn die noch gefährlicheren Lila-Algen daraus entstehen? Oh ja, durch gemeinsame Osmose verbinden die sich. Ja, durch Farbosmose. Na, ich weiß es nicht. Das klingt ehrlich gesagt nach einer horrormässigen Geschichte oder einem Simpsons-Film. Aber ich war auch als Kind schon fasziniert, dass die Blaualgen einen blauen Ausschlag erzeugen. Ja. Also ich hatte blaue Flecken an meinem Körper, weil die Alge selber auch blau, das war so merkwürdig, da dachte ich mir als Kind schon, das ist jetzt ein bisschen comichaft, oder also das ist jetzt ein bisschen viel, dass man sagt, ich habe, das ist so wie wenn du sagst irgendwie, ich habe Ausschlag von einer Sonnenblume und diese Ausschlagflecken sehen so aus wie Sonnenblumen. Wie kleine Sonnenblumen-Tattoos. Du denkst dir, come on, oder? Die Pflanze wird doch nicht nach dem der Farbe benannt, die sie erzeugt. Aber vielleicht habe ich mir das auch eingebildet. Es sind Bakterien auch. Das lese ich gerade zum ersten Mal. Es sind wirklich Bakterien, die dann wahrscheinlich sich so, ach, eklig. Vielleicht waren die Flecken tatsächlich auch nicht blau, muss ich ganz gerade zugeben. Ich habe gerade gegoogelt, blaue Alge ausschlag. Vielleicht habe ich das in meiner kindlichen Fantasie mir so zurechtgelegt und dann selbst kritisiert. Mir für meine eigene Fantasie kritisiert. Ja klar, die klar, die Flecken der Blaualge sind blau, toll gemacht. Das habe ich nämlich häufig, dass ich bei mir in der Wohnung stehe, wenn man mich von außen beobachtet, dann würde ich Wäsche machen zum Beispiel. Dann würde man mich beobachten, wie ich dann, wenn dann so Kameras in meiner Wohnung hingen, würde ich dann so meine Wäsche machen, würde die aufhängen und dann würde ich zwischendurch so innehalten und böse mit dem Kopf schütteln. Was geht in mir vor? Ich streite mit mir selbst. Ich stelle mir vor, was Leute, mit denen man gerade irgendwie ein Argument hat oder führt oder sowas, in gar keinen Sinn auf Deutsch, ich kann so lange in Amerika gelebt, mit denen man gerade einen Streit hat oder wo man wirklich sich Argumente austauscht, keine Ahnung, weil man gerade einen beruflichen Diskurs hat, whatever, oder gerade irgendwie eine SMS-Formulierung, die man abschicken will, eine Mail. Und ich stelle mir immer die schlimmstmögliche Antwort vor in meinem negativen Geist und antworte dann wiederum darauf und ärgere mich dann so über, das ist ja unglaublich. Kann er so dumm sein, hat das Argument immer noch nicht verstanden. Was nimmt Person B sich gerade raus, mir an den Kopf zu knallen, und was ich komplett vergesse, ist, dass das alles in meinem Kopf ist. Und es führt sogar zu dieser körperlichen Reaktion des wüten Kopfschüttelns. Und dann habe ich zwischendurch, als ich mich dann so einen Moment hatte, wo man sich ab und zu von außen betrachtet, hat man ja manchmal, dachte ich dann, du hast einen vollen Knall. Weil das macht ja deinen Tag auch, ruiniert das ja gerade. Ja, und es führt auch dazu, dass du die Person anfängst zu hassen, obwohl sie das nie gesagt hat. Und du das nächste Mal denkst, ey, was für ein Trottel, ey, wirklich, ich habe dir so viele Beispiele gegeben, warum das, was ich sage, richtig ist. Und du denkst trotzdem noch anders. Und dann Realität ist dann, du gehst zu Person B, sagst dann, ich habe mir das nochmal überlegt, bla bla bla, und die Person sagt, ach so ja. Das ist oft die Realität. Und du bist fast ein bisschen enttäuscht, weil du hast 30 richtig gute Argumente. Ordner, Unterordner gehabt. Du hast auf jede Situation baumdiagrammässig, kannst du genau reagieren, nur auf Zustimmung, bist du nicht vorbereitet. Es ist crazy. Und da dachte ich mir wirklich, ja, man ist nicht wirklich der grösste Feind. Man ist selber für seine, weil in deinem Kopf, alles, was in deinem Kopf vorgeht, ist ja die Realität. Warum ist es nicht mehr, warum soll es weniger Realität sein, das Dinge, die actually passieren, weil die nimmst du ja auch wahr. Für dich selber ist das genauso wahr. Wenn ich jetzt anfange, mit mir selber da große Streits zu führen, den Tränen nah, dann bei so. Die Emotionen sind echt. Die Emotionen sind ja trotzdem echt. Wenn man meinen Kopf messen würde, würden ja die gleichen Dinge ausgeschüttet werden, die wahrscheinlich auch bei einem echten Streit ausgeschüttet werden. Und da muss man sich wirklich dann mal zurücknehmen und sagen ... Das heißt, eigentlich ist dann der wirklich auch einfach falsch, weil die Emotionen waren ja da. Du hast ja dann eigentlich gelitten. Der lag ja falsch. Aufgrund von dem Trottel, weil der nicht sofort zugestimmt hat. Bei mir ist es natürlich auch diese Ebene mit diesen YouTube-Kommentaren und Twitter-Kommentaren und so was und Videos und Foreneinträge und so, wo auch Leute irgendwelche Anschuldigungen oder Vorwürfe oder Sachen haben, wo man dann irgendwie darauf reagiert, wo ich auch stundenlang darüber nachdenke, wie kann man das jetzt formulieren, wie kann man dem jetzt genau reindrücken, dass er ein kompletter Vollidiot ist. Was ich mittlerweile mache, weil das bringt ja nichts, dann zu antworten, die Leute sagen ja in der Regel nicht, ach stimmt, du hast recht, sorry, okay, passt. Also das ist noch nie vorgekommen. In meinem Kopf auch nicht. Dass du einen verschreibst, du, was du da sagst, stimmt gar nicht, weil das und das und hier, das habe ich ja da schon gesagt, und deswegen gehst du von falschen Ansprüchen aus, die nie so gemacht wurden. und er sagt, ach stimmt, du hast recht, sorry, da bin ich zufrieden, sondern du verstrickst ja eine unendliche Diskussion. Es passiert manchmal und dann ist es immer viral. Es geht dann immer viral.
Ah, das kann sein, ja.
Manchmal sieht man diese Verläufe im Internet und es ist immer hilarious, weil das passiert ja nie.
Und was ich jetzt mittlerweile mache, ist, ich schreibe die Antwort, aber schicke sie nicht ab, lösche sie dann. Aber ich habe gelernt, dass ich das aus meinem System rauskriegen muss, also dass ich einmal meinen Gedanken klar formuliere und fasse und dir sage, pass auf, so und so und so und so und deswegen habe ich das so gemacht und deswegen hast du das falsch interpretiert und gelesen und ich habe Recht und du hast Unrecht und alles löschen und schliessen und dann ist gut. So, weil dann ist es für mich aus dem System, aber du hast nicht diesen endlosen, weil dann, wenn du mal jemandem antwortest im Internet, dann guckst du ja auch immer, hat er jetzt wieder geantwortet und das geht ja über Wochen, weil du nicht weißt, liest er überhaupt, kriegt er eine Notification für seinen YouTube-Kommentar, wenn ich da kommentiere, liest er das überhaupt, lockt er sich oft in seinen Account ein und über Wochen hast du dieses Ding immer noch im Kopf und führst diese Diskussion weiter und da ist es für mich mittlerweile besser, zu schreiben, nicht abzuschicken und einfach zu wissen, das ist erledigt. Ich habe gesagt, was ich sagen will, zwar nur mir selber, aber das reicht manchmal auch. Aber das ist ja genau mein Punkt. Du hast mit dir selber wieder gesprochen. Du hast dir selber Recht gegeben, weil die ganze Realität, eure ganze Realität findet nur in eurem Kopf statt. Und das ist total, das ist befreiend.
Es klingt so doof, einfach, aber es ist befreiend.
Weil du musst es nicht abschicken. Warum?
Du hast es ja quasi abgeschickt.
In deinem Kopf hast du deine klaren Gedanken gehabt.
Du hast dir bewiesen, dass du recht hast, dass du ein Vollidiot war.
Es hat ja überhaupt nichts mit dem Typen zu tun.
Nein, es ist ja dein innerer Kampf.
Es ist ja einfach nur mein Kampf.
Den habe ich gewonnen und dann ist es auch gut.
So.
Manchmal beschimpfe ich auch einfach. Ja. Kannst du gut beschimpfen eigentlich? Also würdest du sagen, du kannst mal wirklich jemanden, also wirklich treffen mit einem? Oder ist es dann eher so, du Quatschkopf oder so Hampelmann oder so Kasper? Nee, beschimpfen nicht, aber ich kenne schon, wenn ich jemanden gut kenne, dann finde ich schon immer genau die Punkte, die einen extrem nerven.
Dann kannst du auch direkt ins Herz stechen. Ja, ins Herz stechen, ja.
Was würdest du mir sagen, wenn du mich richtig verletzen möchtest?
Nee, das möchte ich nicht sagen.
Aber du hast was im Köcher.
Ja klar, ich habe meine Pfeile im Köcher.
Du hast was im Köcher und wenn es darauf ankommt, würdest du mich niederstrecken.
Ja, dann würde ich so Gefahrenstufen hochsetzen und so und irgendwann würde ich es vielleicht zünden. Und dann könntest du mich mit einem gezielten Stdest du mich niederstrecken. Ja, dann würde ich so Gefahrenstufen hochsetzen und so,
und irgendwann würde ich es vielleicht zünden.
Und dann könntest du mich mit einem gezielten Stich ins Herz niederstrecken.
Ja, wow.
Ich habe nichts, ich muss aufrüsten.
Ich glaube, ich muss aufrüsten, weil ich habe nichts gegen dich.
Ich dachte lange, ich kann mich auch nicht streiten und so,
und streite mich generell nicht, weil wir beiden kennen uns jetzt auch schon sehr lange,
und ich würde sagen, wir haben noch nie gestritten.
Es gab einen Moment, wo du im Recht warst. Was heißt gestritten, aber wo du mal eine Ansage gemacht hast. Wirklich? Ja. Kannst du das offen sagen? Kann ich offen sagen, ja. Und zwar war das ein Dreh zu einem Gute-Arbeit-Original-Sketch, zu dem Nussmann-Sketch. Das war mein erster Regiejob. Genau, du hast Regie geführt. Und da war die Situation so, dass ich relativ zeitig weg musste von diesem Sketch, von diesem Dreh. Weil ich noch einen Termin hatte. Ich hatte noch ein Treffen mit jemandem und deswegen war ich ein bisschen ungeduldig bei diesem Dreh und habe bei manchen Sachen, du hattest dann so Ideen so, ja, lass uns doch mal da und dann läufst du noch mal rum, so ein paar Ideen, die jetzt nicht von Anfang an geplant waren, sondern so ein paar, ey, das wäre noch cool, das und das Bild und ich war eher mit so einem, ah nee, lass uns das mal machen, so wie ist und dann ist es auch gut und dann kamst du wirklich zu mir und meintest so, du pass auf, ich bin jetzt hier Regie und wir machen das jetzt so und du hattest hundertprozentig recht, völlig, du warst komplett im Recht, aber ich hätte nicht gedacht, dass ich, überhaupt nicht, du hattest völlig recht und ich dachte mir wirklich so, ja, nee, stimmt, er hat recht, es ist jetzt meine, ich will eine halbe Stunde früher weg, weil ich mich noch mit jemandem treffe und ich bin gerade so wichtig, es ist völlig fehl am Platz. Ich wusste ja auch, dass es nicht so wichtig war und dass es so ein privates Ding war. Und habe es in dem Moment als unprofessionell empfunden.
Absolut, es war hundert es so ein privates Ding war.
Und ich habe es in dem Moment als unprofessionell empfunden. Absolut, es war hundertprozentig unprofessionell. Rückblickend hasse ich mich aber so dafür, weil das war, weil das mache ich, diese Erfahrung mache ich bei unsicheren Leuten, die etwas zum ersten Mal machen, die noch nicht wirklich fest sind, die müssen immer beweisen, dass sie gerade in der Machtposition sind. Und das schwingt halt auch darin mit, und da hasse ich mich total drin. Ach, ich fand das von dir sehr professionell und sehr, und ich fand es sogar respektabel beim ersten Mal Regie, dass du dann wirklich, weil es ist ja manchmal, glaube ich, schwer, mit Schauspielern zu arbeiten, die dann irgendwie dann so wenig Bock drauf haben, man muss ja motivieren und dann so macht man Abstriche von seiner kreativen Vision, aber bei dir wirklich so, nein, wir machen das jetzt so und wir drehen, solange wir drehen müssen und es ist gut, weil es war halt auch ein Nachtdreh, weil die Szene war halt, dass wir uns nachts auf die Lauer legen. Und wir waren im fucking Schokoladenmuseum. Im Schokoladenmuseum, es war eh eine weirde Situation. In meinem Kopf habe ich auch nicht verstanden, dass Florentin auf all people nichts dringender will als weg hier von diesem Ort. Wir hatten das Schokoladenmuseum als Drehteam für uns allein. Es war jetzt so, gerade weil es Nacht war und irgendwie Drehschluss, ein Uhr, und dann merkte man schon, es wird nicht ein Uhr, und es hat halt noch jemand auf mich gewartet, und ich dachte mir, das wird langsam unhöflich, aber natürlich sind solche privaten Angelegenheiten egal, wenn am Ende gedreht wird. Und nee, da dachte ich mir, okay, krass. Den kann man nicht rumschubsen, wie man will, der gibt schon auch Widerstand, der Stefan. Das ist jetzt noch weiss, weil es fällt mir so einmal im Jahr, fällt mir diese Szene noch mal ein. Ja, wirklich? Und ich hasse, ich war immer der Loser in meinem Kopf. Nee, also ich muss echt sagen, du hast da genau richtig, und ich habe mich danach total schlecht gefühlt. Ja, das glaube ich nämlich auch. Ich habe mich total schlecht gefühlt, weil ich mir dachte, ja, er hat völlig recht, das ist total unprofessionell und hier sind irgendwie 20 Leute am Set, die alle ein cooles Produkt machen wollen und ich nüll da jetzt rum wegen meinen privaten Sachen, die niemanden interessieren und die auch niemanden zu interessieren haben, aber du hattest völlig recht. Ach, der weird. Und am Ende ist es ein brillantes Recht geworden. Ein Emmy Award winning ist es sich absolut gelohnt. Ein Sketch geworden. Ja, rückblickend auch albern, wie man dann sowas so ernst genommen hat in dem Moment. Nein, du musst es ernst nehmen. Das stimmt schon. Anders geht es ja nicht so, du musst dann auch sowas machen. Nee, aber mit dir habe ich nicht oft, habe ich sehr beschreit. Nee, aber seitdem nicht mehr, seitdem hast du deine Machtposition bewiesen und mal wirklich auf den Tisch gehauen. Ich dachte mir, okay, wie so ein Hund Respekt. Der einmal so machen muss, dann ist es gut.
Dann ist es auch gut.
Dann sind die Fronten zwischen Eichhörnchen und Hund geklärt.
Und es kommt nicht aufs Äußerste.
Also du musstest nicht handgreiflich werden, du musstest nicht weitergehen.
Aber danach ist mir auch aufgefallen, ich kann mich mit anderen Menschen auch streiten.
Also mit Freunden streiten.
Im positiven Sinne, das gehört ja auch manchmal dazu. Bei uns beiden würde ich sagen, es gehört nicht dazu. Vielleicht noch nicht, vielleicht streiten wir uns häufiger in Zukunft. Das müsste man richtig krachen lassen. Wie gesagt, ich bin bewaffnet, ich bin bewaffnet, bist du in Zähnen. Weil wir haben jetzt auch eine gemeinsame Verantwortung, wir haben dieses gemeinsame Büro hier, die Brücke, das müssen wir einrichten. Ich sehe hier diese Klebestreifen auf dem Tisch für die ganzen Absorber, die hier noch nicht an den Wänden hängen, sondern immer noch auf dem Boden stehen, wo du eigentlich letzte Woche meintest, du willst dich drum kümmern, hast du nicht gemacht? Habe ich nicht gemacht. Kannst du da kurz was dazu sagen? Ich bin einfach nicht dazu gekommen. Außerdem wollte ich dir auch mal beweisen, dass es nicht alles von alleine passiert, dass du nicht hier jeden Montag magically hinkommst und oh, es ist wieder alles neu, oh, wir haben jetzt einen Tisch, oh, wir haben jetzt Absorber. Ja, das hat wohl irgendjemand gemacht. Es passiert nicht, es sind nicht die Einzelmännchen. Stefan, du bist ja auch richtig. Du machst das mal eine richtige Ansage. Ich bin jetzt im Ansagen bei uns. Nee, wir hängen die noch auf und ihr werdet sagen, what, dann klingt es noch besser? Das klingt noch viel besser? Das klingt ja jetzt schon grandios. Ihr habt euch gerade an den Hall gewohnt und plötzlich klingt es fantastisch? Ne, sagt mal, wir haben jetzt neues Equipment hier, wir sind eigentlich ganz stolz. Das Podcast wird nach sieben Jahren Existenz endlich dann auch mal professionell. Ja. Wir freuen uns darüber sehr, haben jetzt hier unser eigenes kleines Studio. Es würde natürlich helfen, wenn dieser Raum nicht so wahnsinnig leer wäre mit dem Hall. Also falls ihr eine Statue habt oder Billardtisch oder so, schickt ihn uns gerne. Einen sehr kleinen Billardtisch. Schreibt uns bitte davor und dann wirklich einen kleinen Billardtisch, einen Kicker, einen Flipper, irgendwas, was einfach Platz wegnimmt. Wenn ihr eine Couch überhaupt zum Beispiel, oder so ein Sesselchen. So ein Sitzsack, so ein Hackysack oder irgendwie sowas. Oder irgendwie so ein Sessel, der aussieht wie so ein Baseball-Handschuh. Ja, der. Oder ein Kronleuchter, alles was von der Wand hängt, eine Disco-Kugel. Ich habe nämlich gedacht, weil das ja schon so ein typisches Steuerberatungsbüro ist, so sehr, noch sehr kalt. Super kalt. Und die ganze Etage ist auch kalt. Und zu den Leuten ist man auch noch sehr kollegial distanziert. Ich fände es ja super, wenn wir hier so ein bisschen Extravaganz reinbringen würden. So ein bisschen exzentrik. Wir haben nämlich das Potenzial, wir kennen noch niemanden auf dem... Naja, wir haben einmal schon eine kleine Freundschaft geknüpft. Genau, aber wir haben sonst noch nicht viele Bekanntschaften gemacht. Wir haben noch das Potenzial, zu diesen Rockstar-Exzentriken auf der Etage zu werden. Mir würde ja schon helfen, wenn wir so einen großen Kronleuchter hinhängen können. Kronleuchter wäre gut, oder so ein Thron oder irgendwas, was extravagant ist, wirklich so ein, vielleicht so ein Tigerfell oder so ein Bärenfell, dass wir so an die Wand hängen können, irgendwas in der Ecke sowas. Also falls ihr irgendwas, falls ihr irgendwie Fürst seid oder so, oder einfach viel Luxuskram rumliegen habt, schickt uns das. Genau, falls ihr irgendwas habt, was schreit, guckt mich an, ich bin ein Rockstar, ich bin exzentrisch, hi, das hätten wir gerne hier. Skulptur oder irgendwie sowas. Ja, sowas. So eine richtig hässliche Skulptur. So eine Madonna, so eine Riesen-Madonna, stellen wir einfach hier hin. Und man kann durch die Glastür, wenn man hier langläuft, wir sind auch das erste Büro, also alle müssen immer an uns vorbei. Und es ist einfach Glas. Und es ist eine Glastür und nicht Wirbelglas. Finde es schon gut, wenn man dahinter erahnt, what the fuck is happening. Und warum höre ich diesen Brunnenplätschern da drin? Und was sind das Vögel? Ich finde es gut, so ein paar Geheimnisse hier aufzumachen. Auf jeden Fall, finde ich gut, die Idee, ansonsten breiten wir uns noch weiter aus. Und ja, wir haben auch Bock, uns so ein bisschen einzudecken mit den ganzen coolen Grafiken, die ihr gemacht habt, von dem UFO. Ihr könnt ja auf unserer Website das UFO runterladen als Datei und dann damit machen, was ihr wollt. Ja. Es in verschiedenen Situationen machen, wir posten da auch ab und zu was auf Instagram, da kommen immer sehr, sehr viele coole Grafiken auch rein. Und die wollen wir auch so ein bisschen aufbereiten und hier aufhängen. Das ist die Idee, ja. So ein bisschen euren Community-Input mit dem UFO, was ihr alles Tolles gebastelt habt. Also falls ihr Bock habt, hier verewigt zu werden an unserer großen Community-Wand, dann könnt ihr auch da gerne neue Sachen einschicken. Wir sind immer auf der Suche nach neuen, coolen Grafiken. Generell, genau. Immer neue, neue Intros schicken, neue Cover schicken und dann schauen wir, was wir damit anstellen können. Oder freuen wir uns auf nächste Woche. Haut rein, wir wünschen euch eine schöne Zeit.
Macht's gut, entspannt euch mal.
Wir erwarten alle Antworten.
Entspannt euch mal.
Wie gesagt, der Merch, der ist jetzt immer da.
Schaut da mal rein.
Ihr habt genug Zeit, erst im Ufo-Club euch anzumelden, um dann den Rabatt abzugreifen.
Ist alles kein Problem.
Um euch dann wieder abzumelden.
Auch oder dann nochmal anzumelden.
Und das kriegt ihr schon hin.
Ansonsten sehen wir uns nächste Woche wieder.
Bis dahin, heben wir ab.
Macht's gut. Ciao.
Ciao.